[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 les invités voici les
titres à l'occasion des 60 ans du traité
de rome qui marque les fondations de
l'union européenne nous recevons marc
joly docteur en histoire à l'université
versailles saint quentin et auteur du
livre l'europe de jean monnet en sport
la saison de baseball reprend ce week
end
nouveau challenge pour les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux qui évolue cette
année en d1
quels sont les objectifs pour l'équipe
nous les verrons avec le coach de
l'équipe senior rodolphe lebel mon début
de cette émission avec le 60e
anniversaire du traité de rome le 25
mars 1957 six pays donné naissance à la
communauté économique européenne
ancêtre de notre actuelle union
européenne cet anniversaire arrive alors
que les ep face aux briques site et à la
désaffection de son système pour en
discuter avec nous ce soir marc joly
professeur à dubé est ce qu il a
d'ailleurs écrit un livre sur le sujet
l'europe de jean monnet bonsoir ça alors
c'est 60 ans plus tard quel constat on
peut faire c'est un anniversaire un peu
morose parce qu'il manque un pays qui a
rejoint en cours de route
la communauté européenne qui est la
grande bretagne qui vient de le décider
de sortir
c'est un moment où l'europe est bloqué
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord parce
qu'il ya des élections politiques très
importantes cette année en 2017 et
ensuite parce qu'il ya des problèmes
structurels qui sont
voilà en cours depuis très longtemps qui
ne sont pas résolues que ce serait un
problème de l'euro que ce soit le
problème de la fermeture constitutionnel
de l'europe c'est à dire est ce qu'on va
pouvoir créer une unité politique
symbolique autour d'un texte d'un texte
constitutionnel
et puis à la question turque aussi qui
n'a pas été résolue l'avion mais le
faire évoluer les négociations
d'adhésion sont soi-disant maintenu mais
personne n'y croit donc à une forme
d'hypocrisie actuellement autour de ces
trois grandes questions c'est pas on
sait pas comment les résoudre en fait
pour l'angleterre charles de gaulle
n'était pas vraiment d'accord pour
l'arrivée de l'angleterre
maintenant qu'on voit le break site il
avait raison ah oui là je crois qu'il
avait raison vie et il était
effectivement contre il a initié
toujours opposés et c'est son successeur
pompidou qu favoriser l'entrée de la
grande-bretagne dans l'europe à l'époque
s'appelait la comité économique européen
d'actes mans mendès france disait que
l'europe si elle est mal gérée il y
aurait des difficultés avec la
concurrence redoutable
en ce temps là des chômeurs italien ou
allemand aujourd'hui il a été
visionnaire de certaines personnes ne
dirai c'est évident il était
effectivement très très réservé à propos
du marché commun il a d'ailleurs voté
contre à l'assemblée nationale donc
alors que c'est quelqu'un qui m'aime pro
européen qui a toujours été pro européen
là il avait une vision vraiment
économique des choses en disant ça ne
peut pas marcher ou si ça marche ça va
dans le sens du moins disant social donc
lui il est précurseur sur sur pleins
d'éléments je pense que pour certains
candidats de gauche à l'élection
présidentielle c'est clairement une
source d'inspiration
aujourd'hui il manque un moteur à
l'union européenne
vous qui avez écrit un livre sur le
sujet que je montre ici il manque un mot
un moteur il faut il faut un
gouvernement qu'est ce qui se passe où
on le dit souvent je l'entends souvent
une europe plus pour les peuple pour le
peuple
elle est passée pour le peuple 1 le
problème c'est que il ya deux problèmes
sert d'abord l'europe elle a toujours
été impulsée par la france toutes les
grandes avancées de la construction
européenne ont été le fait de soi
représentants politiques français en
fonction soit de français à la tête
d'institutions européennes comme jacques
delors et c'est vrai que la france n'est
plus motrices en matière européenne
il ya aussi un décalage qui s'est créée
entre la france et l'allemagne tirent
que la base il ya quand même une forme
de deux couples très très fort ce qui
déséquilibre est aujourd'hui qu'il était
d'une certaine manière aux bleus au
bénéfice de la france parce que sur un
plan symbolique l'allemagne avait
beaucoup de chemin à rattraper et
aujourd'hui qu'il est effectivement
économiquement industriellement sur le
plan des des règles budgétaires en
faveur de l'allemagne
donc ça ça crée un vrai problème on est
là de la manière dont vous m'expliquer
ce couple on est dans un rapport de
forces est ce qu'il faudrait pas créer
un gouvernement européen
ce que de la manière dont vous
m'expliquez cela c'est l'allemagne qui
dirige très clairement c'est pas
vraiment l'allemagne qui dirige c'est un
peu ce serait lui même et disons qu'ils
ont des arguments à faire valoir et ils
veulent pas dérogé de leur position qui
consiste à dire faut que les pays soient
bien gérées et fasse attention à leurs
déficits pour qu'on puisse pour qu'on
puisse avancer donc il ya un vrai il ya
par exemple une vraie opposition sur la
manière dont les
les élites allemandes et les élites
françaises se représente la viabilité de
l'euro clairement les françaises disent
il faut qu'ils aient plus de solidarité
budgétaire à l'échelle de la zone euro
et les allemands disent non non ce qu'il
faut c'est que les pays soient mieux
gérées fasse des efforts en termes de
gestion des budgets et là il n'ya pas de
pour l'instant de compromis possible
sauf à ceux à se placer sur le terrain
des allemands qui consiste à dire gérons
d'abord bien nos comptes et ensuite on
pourra négocier des avancées politiques
c'est par exemple la position de macron
et il a d'autres positions c'est banon
il faut engager un bras de fer pour
changer les règles ça c'est plutôt
mélenchon bon les deux sont difficiles
les deux sont difficiles et risquées
très rapidement pour vous l'avenir de
l'europe
elle passe par quoi elle passe d'abord
par une analyse la plus objective
possible des sources de dysfonction
dysfonctionnement par un discours de
vérité qu'il n'est pas tenu
malheureusement elle tient aussi
peut-être à inventer quelque chose qui
soit une initiative en dehors du système
de l'union européenne de type fédéral
peu importe quelque chose de positif qui
puisse entraîner les peuples mais à
l'échelle de l'union européenne telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui c'est très très
difficile de faire progresser des
projets d'envergure c'est un vrai souci
et bien je vous remercie monsieur marc
joly puis je précise que vous avez écrit
un livre qui s'intitule l'europe de jean
monnet n'hésitez pas à aller le
consulter
on va parler un petit peu de baseball
vous y connaissez nous écouter nous
rester avec nous c'est très intéressant
donc comme je disais on passe au sport
on va parler donc de l'équipe des
cougars qui débutent leur saison ce week
end l'équipe évoluera cette saison en
première division pour se maintenir le
club à réaliser en gros recrutement avec
de nombreux jeunes à fort potentiel nous
allons en parler avec monsieur rodolphe
le meur le coach de l'équipe senior
bonsoir soir alors ces recrutements est
une bonne chose où il fallait laisser
une certaine continuité
aussi vous avez recruté c'est que on est
important c'est important c'est vrai que
pour pouvoir
se distinguer et puis pouvoir assurer un
peu notre notre saison en championnat au
niveau en tout cas français il faut il
faut recruter en plus beaucoup de deux
d'anciens joueurs n'ont pas voulu non
pas souhaité continuer avec nous parce
qu'ils avaient des obligations que ça
soit on reste un sport amateur donc on a
quand même des obligations personnelles
donc ils n'ont certains joueurs n'ont
pas voulu continuer avec nous donc sont
restés dans la division inférieure donc
il fallait quand même récupérer et
recruter encore notre but aussi c'était
surtout d'aller rechercher les tous les
jeunes que qu'on a perdu depuis ces
dernières années ça fait quand même six
anciens volets sens de vue c'est bien ça
c'est ça fait six ans qu'on va cherche à
remonter on s'arrête en demi finale donc
là on a réussi quand même à remonter
c'est vrai que c'était très important de
le faire puisque justement toutes ces
jeunes que l'essence même du globe
c'est vraiment la formation des jeunes
et beaucoup de jeunes où on enrôle on a
perdu beaucoup la congruence alors pas
tous encore certains sont encore en
étant discussions certains sont en phase
d'observation parce que c'est un retour
c'est un retour donc au haut niveau
certains nous ont dit on va regarder un
peu ce que vous faites et puis peut-être
qu'on viendra d'autres des obligations
devront partir à l'étranger
on en a récupéré quand même on a
récupéré des jamais lisse à mes yeux
c'est quand même qu'ils devaient aller
jouer aux états unis si ce qui sera
sûrement y aller mais au moins voilà
cette année elle a souhaité rejoindre
son club d'origine
ce qui est vraiment un plaisir voilà
enfin si tu es vraiment et le
recrutement il est vraiment essentiel
pour ça pour pouvoir aussi se battre
contre les grosses équipes donc ses
joueurs qu'ils disent je vais attendre
de voir qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce
que vous leur dites vous cette année
vous avez prévu quoi
alors cette année le maintien oui
remporté non il faut se donner des
ambitions dans le sport on s'en est
donné l'année dernière ça a fonctionné
pourquoi pas cette année alors on va
essayer d'aller chatouiller les grosses
écuries auront sénart montpellier et on
notre objectif c'est d'être dans les
quatre premiers sincèrement
on se donne quand même bonnes ambitions
c'est ce qu'on se dit toujours il faut
il faut toujours viser le plus haut pour
pour l'atteindre voilà aujourd'hui on a
vraiment cette ambition et sincèrement
avec l'équipe qu'on a aujourd'hui on a
on a ce qu'il faut pour aller titiller
les grosses écuries et se placer en haut
de tableau donc clairement c'est c'est
possible vous y avait là on y croit
fortement et on va encore se sont là
travaillé tout l'hiver pour savoir ça
fait trois mois qu'on s'entraîne quatre
mois qu'on se prépare en en gymnase en
intérieur tout ce qui est physique et là
on vient de finir notre préparation en
faisant une dizaine de matches en
participant à certains tournois vous
avez pu le rencontrer certaines rien
fait on a rencontré la première journée
savigny-sur-orge qui fait partie la d1
qu'on a battu deux fois
on a rencontré à montpellier on est allé
faire un tournoi là bas à montpellier on
a rencontré saint-just-saint-rambert
notre adversaire de la finale qu'on
aurait battu encore une fois donc on a
on a 50 50 on l'a on à montpellier
encore la grosse machine montpellier on
a eu un peu plus de mal mais on les a on
n'a pas été un choc mais voilà on les a
bien fait encore on est parti nous ont
dit ah oui quand-même montini ils sont
là quand même on est pas on n'est pas
monté par hasard vous avez une revanche
à prendre compte de ces années où vous
êtes descendus maintenant nous y est
c'est un long voyage si le cacher oui
c'est vrai que ça fait six ans qu'on
attend ça c'est pour dire et je parlerai
pas de revanche mais c'est vrai qu'on a
on a envie de montrer que mon signal à
sa place en d1 est en tout cas on va
faire tout pour pouvoir montrer aux
autres équipes et et on est attendus
sincèrement quand on essaie on écoute un
peu les autres équipes je connais pas
mal d'entraîneurs de l'équipe de
division 1 et ils nous attendent ils
nous attendent sincèrement donc on est
on a à coeur de montrer que montigny a
vraiment sa place en division à cette
année cette équipe que vous avez
remaniée c'est quoi les points forts
maintenant cette année alors aujourd'hui
on a donc fait venir
quatre anciens joueurs de l'équipe de
chartres et charte qui est descendu de
division donc ce sont des joueurs qui
ont entre 2 et 4 ans déjà de
l'expérience en division une
s'ils vont pouvoir amener leur
expérience aux nouveaux joueurs et on a
quand même aussi d'anciens joueurs qui
ont aussi pratiqué en d1 brouille à 5-6
ans je pense que le niveau un peu un peu
évolué maintenant voilà tout s'est tu
vas on va essayer de créer vraiment une
osmose entre les anciens les petits
jeunes aussi on a été chercher beaucoup
de jeunes aussi parce qu'on veut on est
toujours gelé 17 essence de on a cet
essor de feu de club formateur on veut
aussi que les jeunes puissent jouer à
haut niveau
donc on a un certain jeunes du pôle du
pôle espoirs de rouen et aussi du pôle
france de toulouse
donc on veut vraiment c'est ce qu'elle
était ça a été le but aussi de cette
préparation de faire ces matches c'est à
dire de douala de créer ce groupe est de
faire en sorte que voilà c'est tout ce
groupe avancé la même dynamique
donc les anciens qui ont des expériences
avec les nouveaux là le dynamisme la la
force la puissance des des nouveaux
puissent voilà c'est juste fait 5
millions qu'on croque ont créé ce groupe
pour vraiment faire des exploits on va
dire en division une
très rapidement ce premier match vous
affrontez clairement faire mon camp et
aux ours et dimanche 2 avril donc c'est
à partir de 10h50 le play ball donc ça
le le début du match et à 11 heures pour
le premier match est le deuxième match
en général c'est vers 14 heures et pour
nos téléspectateurs pour venir le voir
ce match oui il faut venir le voir parce
que c'est vraiment notre montée cc il va
y avoir de l'ambiance on va essayer de
créer un peu cette ambiance un peu c'est
un sport américain donc on va faire en
sorte de créer cette ambiance une
ambiance à l'américaine pour que voilà
ce qu'il va voir lecce 2-2 de
d'elancourt de que parce qu on est on
est très amis avec les templiers
d'elancourt desquels football américain
donc voilà on va essayer vraiment de
créer de faire un événement de ceux de
cette première journée c'est un opening
et en plus on a la chance de le faire
chez nous c'est vrai que certains
certains clubs partent à l'extérieur
faire leurs premiers journées nous on a
la chance de faire un bon signe donc on
va faire en sorte que ce soit un vrai
spectacle et j'invite tout le monde
nouveau et bien je vous remercie je vous
remercie tous les deux d'être venu sur
le plateau
c'est la fin de ce set 8 les invités
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]